well it was a great breakthrough when  a single cell was developed compared to  bug dna it allowed us to  specifically study separate cells  but when we  analyze data using single cell we end up  with something like this uh cells in an  artificial dimensions in this case it's  umap but we never really know where  exactly in our tissue the cells are  located  um and with spatial transcriptomics  finally we have this opportunity to map  the cells to our tissue but other than  organs we also can look at for example  biofilm populations  um this is the clustering of different  functions that cells individual cells  it's used a lot in medicine also it's  very useful to identify the invasive  margin of the tumor and actually how the  cells this cancer interact